- I've got rhythm in my bones.
I've got rhyme in my bones,
you know what I'm sayin'?
In my blood so when I hear a dope beat
I just have to go.
My imagery is a lot darker and less,
you know, it's not easy
to swallow to some people,
you know what I mean?
But I won't change it for the world.
I'm actually doing music
'cause I love to do it.
You know I don't have to
do it but I want to do it
because that's all I know.
Because I always
had something special I just
been waitin' on 'erybody
to fucking get it.
- He's a rapper, song
writer, record producer,
actor, and entrepreneur.
He's sold over two million albums
and have had his songs featured in film,
TV and video games.
He's one of the biggest
selling independent rappers
in the United States.
He's Tech N9ne and here's my take on his
top ten rules for success.
Rule number three is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also as Tech N9ne is
talking if he says something
that's really meaningful to you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(bright orchestral music)
- I got rhythm in my bones.
I got rhyme in my bones,
you know what I'm sayin'?
And in my blood, so
when I hear a dope beat
I just have to go, you
know what I'm sayin'?
Even if I'm tired and life is (bleep) up,
because of the divorce ain't let up yet,
you know what I'm sayin'?
My young one is sick,
Family is turnin' on you 'cause of money
and (bleep) like that?
Still when that dope beat hit
you're compelled to write on it,
you know what I'm sayin'?
and bust on it, you know what I'm sayin'?
As long as I stay that way,
man, I just turned 45 November 8th.
- [Male Host] My man.
- [Female Host] Oh wow.
(audience clapping)
- You know what I'm sayin'?
I just turned 45 and I feel 22,
(man laughs)
you know what I'm sayin'?
I don't feel like I'm going to slow down
no time soon brother.
Well a lot of artists don't know that they
got to get on the goddamn road and tour,
you know what I'm saying'?
You got to get the people
knowin' about you, man.
You know, not just your hot single, man.
You got to get out there and politic.
How do you politic?
Through touring, man.
You know what I'm saying'?
Merchandise.
You got a shirt with your name on it?
You got a hat with your name on it?
You know, these people
are walkin' billboards,
you know what I'm saying'?
- [Female Host] Exactly.
- You know you got to get
out there and politic, man.
And that's how we did it.
Man we just stayed on the
road and even if there
were like seven people in
the audience when we went,
we didn't say "Okay, we ain't
goin' back to San Diego,
"'cause only seven people there" or
"We ain't goin' back to New York 'cause we
"only had ten people there."
We kept comin' back
and hammerin' them over
the head and the seven turned to a 100.
The 100 turned 500,
you know what I'm saying'?
To sellin' out every time
that we had to change venues.
You know what I'm saying'?
You got to get out there and politic, man.
You got to get out there and tour.
You got to get out there and
sell your merchandise, man.
And a lot of people, you know,
they ain't gon' tell you
this but it take a little
money to start your own label.
You feelin' me?
It take a little money to
start it, you know what I mean?
So all you niggas selling
that shit in the hood
put it into something good.
If it's in your heart,
you have to push for it.
If it's in your heart.
Because, I'm from Kansas City, Missouri,
who would have ever thought that
you can build an empire,
but if you put your mind to it,
and push for it, and push for it,
no matter if your family
tell you it's a hobby,
you need to do something else
to get money, or whatever man
it's like, if you believe in it,
you got to follow that dream
in your heart man because,
if I didn't, there wouldn't be
any strange music to
come do any interviewin'.
Because I followed my dream.
After everybody knocked me down.
You have to push for
it, if you believe in it
you will achieve in it.
Just got to keep pushin'.
That's what I have to say.
Morris asked me, "Why don't
you write somethin' and rap,
"instead of spittin' on everybody."
And I wrote it, and everybody liked it,
and I started doin' it more,
and then I finally won a contest,
first thing I ever won in my life.
The thing I won fell on my graduation day,
so I chose to open up for EPMD,
and Kwamé, all those people,
at Kemper arena, in Kansas City, Missouri,
rather than walk across the stage,
right up the street where all
my partners were graduating,
and that's when I knew
what I was going to do
for the rest of my life, you know.
Your graduation day, you get your diploma,
and you choose something else,
and then you end up doin' what you do,
what you planned on doin'.
And you're young, and
it's not written in blood
that you're going to make it,
and you move from house to house,
because you ran away from home at 17,
you move from place to place,
with family members and
friends and everything,
trying to do music and
then you end up doin' it,
then you end up on the Forbes list,
and working with all the
people that inspired you,
like Ice Cube, and The
Doors, and Roger Troutman,
you know, it's wonderful,
you know what I'm sayin'.
So that was the most monumental to me.
You know, I write my life,
I'm not like a lot of rappers,
you know what I'm sayin',
that write what they think is hot, or now.
I'll write what's happening in my life,
whether it's partyin',
whether it's sorrowful,
whether it's confused,
you know what I mean,
I'll write that.
And, with that bein'
said, what inspires me
is either reading something,
or having something happen to me,
that's why I don't
believe in writers block.
You know what I mean?
Only thing I believe in is style block,
how am I going to say this to people
to make them listen.
♫ Narcissistic
♫ Hard to grip it
♫ Dark and wicked
♫ Arts prolific
♫ Mars with the stars, this is far lifted
♫ Lyrics, quit the bawitibaw
scriptures are terrific,
♫ Get a spitter with a
bit of bitter marketed,
♫ With scrilla then a
fifth of Henny liquor
♫ Start to twist it
It's like, style block is the thing,
but writers block, no, never.
My very first album in '96
was The Calm Before The Storm.
So I knew, 20 years later,
If I named this album The Storm,
it was going to push
me to do the best music
I could possibly do, and I did it.
And I know I ain't supposed
to say that, but it's real.
- What makes you say that though.
- Beause I'm always feelin' like
I have a chip on my shoulder
and I have to prove myself
because I'm the weird kid,
you know what I'm sayin',
I look different, I paint my
face, this, that and the other.
You know what I'm sayin',
my imagery is a lot darker,
and less, it's not easy
to swallow to some people,
you know what I mean,
but I won't change it for the world,
because they going to
have to accept all of me,
not just one dimension of
me, you know what I mean,
but when you got that
other dimension going up,
you know what I mean, like
he'll go crazy and fragile,
you know what I'm sayin'.
People tend to try to say,
"You should just do that one thing",
but I'm three.
You know what I'm sayin', I'm not one.
So they got to accept all of me.
I always knew that I
had something special,
and that's just validation
after all these years
for Eminem to come through,
for Slipknot to come
through and do that for me,
and I've been a maggot since '99,
for those who don't know what a maggot is,
it's a Slipknot fan, you
know, it's a metal band,
you know, for those people
to come through for me
that I've been wanting to
work with for over a decade,
and you have to take the
beat to these people,
and the thought like,
you have to give them something
that they really like.
I had to play that for Corey Taylor
backstage at an arena,
you know what I'm saying.
- What's going through your
head while you're playing it?
Are you like watching
their facial expressions
to see if they're with it.
- No.
- Are you looking down,
like what's going on.
- Well, I'm at a point in my life,
where I know this shit is
dope, you know what I'm sayin'.
So, I'm playin' it for him,
like smilin', you know,
and they listenin' to me, and
they hear some of my lyrics,
and they start smilin', and
then I start smilin' some more,
and then Corey Taylor was like,
"Okay, what if I said, da-da-da-da-da-la",
you know, like woah, yeah, yes, yes.
You know what I'm sayin', so it's just,
it feels wonderful to work with people
that you've been listening
to for over a decade,
and being right there with them,
and they with you, all the
way man, you know what I mean.
I have no words.
Even though I just said a lot
of words, I have no words.
- It's just dope to see
you so excited about it,
I mean you know some people
been in the industry,
and then they're just like,
"Yeah the albums coming out."
- No.
- You're hype bro,
and it's like a whole
new life and energy bro.
- Oh it is a whole new life,
every time an album comes out man,
but this one is by far my
best work, in my opinion.
I'm actually doing music
because I love to do it.
You know, I don't have to do it,
but I want to do it,
because that's all I know.
Fragile was good, a really good song,
but it's political man,
you know what I'm sayin',
they don't know what to do with this guy,
you know what I'm sayin'.
So now that Everybody But Me is just me
and with Bizzy on the
hook, and Krizz Kaliko,
it's going to be harder, because
they just got to sell me.
Like, okay, you ain't
got no features on it?
Not Kevin Gates?
Which I love Kevin Gates,
but not Kevin Gates?
You don't have Future on it?
You don't have Young Thug on it?
Wait, it's just Tech N9ne?
okay, we'll see, let us listen.
It's a good song.
So it's workin', but we going to see.
You know what I'm sayin', it's harder,
so people, your question
was, you know, is it weird
that everybody's on the jock right now,
I expected it,
because I always had something special.
I just been waiting on
everybody to fuckin' get it.
This is how I built it though,
I wanted it to be, I
wanted Tech N9ne to be
my favorite MC times ten,
you know what I'm sayin'.
So I painted him that way, you know,
I actually painted him too.
In regular form, I'm really respectful.
But when that face paint goes on,
I'm (bleep).
- Is that why you do it,
to sort of transform into another
character, the face paint.
- I think it's not transforming
into another character,
I think it's like shielding
me, and what's inside of me,
actually, what's in there will come out,
you know what I'm sayin',
but I wouldn't regularly say
to people in regular form,
you know what I'm sayin',
because I'm a pretty shy dude, so.
The face paint is kind of like a shield,
like okay I can hide behind this,
and say whatever the (bleep) I want to,
you know what I'm sayin',
I can tell the world that
I don't give a (bleep),
you know what I'm sayin'.
If it ain't about love, I'll
(bleep) you up, you know.
So, yeah I think that face
paint does a lot for me.
I know it does,
I feel like a superhero
when that (bleep) on.
I want people to know that I
bring love through music, man
you know, I bring happiness,
even if it's dark man,
you know, a lot of the soldiers
from Afghanistan come to me
and they say, "You got me through
when I was over there man,
"your music got me through."
Even doctors coming to my shows and say,
"Man, that song The Rain,
"where you're talking about
being away from your children,
"I felt it."
You know, athletes come to me,
"Man, that song", you
know what I'm sayin',
"Riot Maker gets me pumped
up before the show."
you know what I mean,
James Hetfield, of Metallica, said,
"We love Einstein", you
know what I'm sayin',
"We listen to Einstein before we go on."
You know, just crazy stuff man.
I want to be remembered for
the guy that brought happiness,
you what I'm sayin', the guy that brought
that stuff that was so influential, man,
you know what I mean,
even if I'm talking about
me almost dying from drugs, you know,
been clean for like four years,
I know it didn't look like it
when I was just scratching my neck,
but I been clean for four years.
I just want to be the guy that they know
that was 100% inside-out.
He gave everything.
And my reward is great.
And my fan base keeps growing
and growing and growing man,
right before my eyes.
It's crazy.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
Mad Marlan asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
what did Tech N9ne say
that had the biggest impact on you,
what did you learn from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
to your business or life.
Please leave it in the comments below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally wanted to give a quick shout out
to Jennifer Price,
Jennifer thank you so much
for being in the book,
helping with the book,
but also taking that awesome picture
while you're doing Christmas shopping,
and posting it as well,
I really really really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- But here's the thing though,
people see you on stage, they
see you on tour for years,
we know you do well, it's documented.
But I try to get
onlookers, fans, listeners,
to understand that there's
no difference necessarily
in people, so--
- Nah, we all have the same emotions.
- Same emotions, we're all
going through the same issues,
and even though you see
Tech N9ne on this show,
Sway in the Morning,
or you might see him on
some award show stage,
behind closed doors, he's
experiencing the same thing
your neighbor might be experiencing.
- And that's how we make fans
man, you know what I'm sayin'.
That brings us down on
a level playing field,
you know what I mean,
'cause they look at us elevated, on stage,
they automatically lookin' up.
So when you tell them,
"I'm havin' a bad day
"because my people are turnin' on me,
"and I thought these people were real,"
it brings us on a level playing field,
and they're like, "He feels just like me."
and that's how we make fans,
you know what I'm sayin'.
I tapped into emotions,
and a lot of my fans know about my life
because I put it in my
records, you know what I mean,
to where the wife used to,
when This Ring came out,
well she didn't like that,
you know what I'm sayin',
back then but This Ring is like
the best song I ever wrote.
Pain works, you know what I
mean, so when I did the song
I Love You But (bleep) You, she said,
"Don't write nothing else
about me if it ain't positive."
and I said, "Okay, I'll stop it."
(laughter)
- [Female Host] No more songs about her.
You know what I'm sayin',
my little girl Rainbow said
that she didn't like me to
do the lewd stuff on stage,
like how I would do the song Seven Words
and lay in between the ladies,
you know what I'm sayin',
so I stopped that, you
know what I'm sayin',
It's like, I do what they
say, you know what I'm sayin',
these ladies that I take care
of, you know what I'm sayin',
and Aaliyah, she's just, she's 22 now man,
she's out there in Oakland,
just having a wonderful time,
doing broadcasting and everything,
she don't have too many problems.
Rainbow, I can't really talk about
what's going on with my little
one 'cause she don't want it,
but she got sick man, and I was just like,
"God why me," you know what I'm sayin'.
And she's probably like "God why me,"
you know what I'm sayin'
and my mama was sick all those years,
and now my youngster,
you know what I'm saying,
it's like damn, but in
the midst of all that,
we still have time to
give ourselves to our fans
and our people that want to
hear, 'cause it's a blessing
for people to want to hear anything,
especially these days being in the game
as long as I've been,
you know what I mean,
it's like, it's such a blessing,
that they still want to listen.
And I'm going to forever
have these stories to tell,
because I'm writin' my life,
and that's what I chose
to do back in the day
when Quincy Jones told me,
"Write what you know and
people will forever feel you."